تحقيق يورث برشلونه في رشوه نيمار وميسي
الاسوا امام بايرن ميونخ يسافر مع تشيلسي
رغم تجميده هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم
من العربيه الرياضه اهلا بكم
ارتباك داخل اروقه نادي برشلونه بعد تورته
في قضيه رشوه لنائب رئيس لجنه الحكام
الاسبانيه بين عامي 2016
و2018 وكانت شركه التابعه للحكم حسين ريكي
قد خضعت لتحقيقات بسبب تهرب ضربي واكتشف
من خلاله حاولت من
الشركه على ثلاث دفعات البارصا وفي بيان
رسمي له لم ينفي هذه الاخبار بل حاول
احتوائها
كشف البرازيلي رودريغو لاعب ريال مدريد
الاسباني ان نجوم الفريق قد سئموا من
العنصريه التي يتعرضون لها في الملاعب هذا
الموسم وخاصه زميله فينيسيوس جونيور وكان
فيني قد تعرض لصيحات عنصريه خلال مباراه
فريقه امام ريال مايوركا مضيفا بان رابطه
الدوري الاسبانيه لا تحميهم داخل الملاعب
مره اخرى يبدو سنجر اقرب المغادره دوري
ابطال اوروبا بعد خسارته على ارضه امام
بايرن ميونخ الالماني اجمل فريق ميسي
ونيمار تلاقي تقييم ثلاثه من عشره بحسب
صحيفه ليكيب الشهيره فيما اجمع المتابعون
ان اداء الفريق تحسن بعد دخول مبابي ما
يطرح فعليا فرضيه التخلي عن ميسي ونيمار
في الصيف المقبل وبناء المشروع جديد
يتمركز حول نجم الفرنسيه الشاب
اظهر اوباميان احترافيه كبيره مع فريقه
تشيلسي حيث سافر اللاعب الكابوني مع فريقه
لمواجهه ناديها السابق دورتموند رغم خروجه
من القائمه الاوروبيه للفريق اللندني ورغم
منحه الاذن للسفر الى اي مدينه يريدها
خلال منتصف الاسبوع
اثر استبعاده من التشكيله الاساسيه للفريق
بعد ان انتقل اليه قادم من برشلونه مطلع
الموسم الحالي